foreign
they're getting more powerful every day
armed gang members in Ganan on the
outskirts of Port-au-Prince the UN
estimates gangs now control 80 percent
of the Haitian capital
but gang members say they're the least
of Hades many troubles
people say gangs like ours are the
country's biggest problem but where do
we find all these weapons people live in
areas without food water roads and
hospitals and the accusers of being the
country's problem we leave it for the
state to answer
Haiti has been
of an economic and political crisis for
years with violence spiraling out of
control following the assassination of
President jovenel Moyes in 2021.
Alexandra mccandry's House was set on
fire by armed groups trying to take
control of another part of the capital
as you can see all these are people who
burned inside the house they could not
be saved during The Invasion so many
people died this is a terrible thing
that happens in the country
people have been displaced because of
the violence many are living in shelters
often unable to go back to their homes
franchise commission's husband was
executed by gang members
while my husband was trying to enter the
house they took him shot him and burned
him with his motorcycle that's why I
came to the shelter with my children
when I returned home our house was
completely burnt I didn't save anything
my husband was a motorcycle driver he
was the one who took care of all the
family
Haiti lacks the trained Security Forces
needed to help the state regain control
over lost territory
six months ago the government requested
International military assistance but
nothing so far has come to the appeal
Rhys and leaked U.S intelligence
documents show that Russia's Wagner
group was offering help in fighting the
gangs
analy say that's not the answer to the
country's problems
I think that we need to find our
Solutions ourselves and I think the
United States needs to be more proactive
in helping us out but we we think we
need to work with the with the diaspora
the International Community and Haiti to
find a solution the Wagner group from
Russia you know it has its reputation
we've seen some videos this is not
something that we're looking forward to
while the International Community tries
to find a solution thousands remain
trapped in the chaos that has taken over
their daily lives